a magazine interview with Dwayne Johnson
the only rock your girlfriend would
rather get that an engagement ring has
been getting a lot of attention today
because of one interesting revelation
his legitimate desire to run for
president I have no problem with this at
all I think compared to trump the rock
is a much better choice you guys first
of all first of all his tan is real
secondly his clothes actually fit as
opposed to Trump who always looks like
he's trying to smuggle a yoga ball in a
court show and if you wanted to the rock
could destroy way more people in
Atlantic City it's amazing I love them
love the rock but see here's where I
just have a slight problem
slight problem and please don't get mad
at me the rock so this interview with
Dwayne the POTUS Johnson was on the
cover of GQ magazine comedy issue that's
a cavity issue the comedy issue look at
that comedy bicep right there on the
front of a comedy issue I mean I guess
this makes sense you know considering
next month I'm featured in fire hydrant
arm magazine 50 Polynesians who can't
sit in the Prius issue
but GQ guys I know you want to sell
magazines I get it but try to understand
what's going on and what comedy actually
means all right thousands of comedy
folks they could have put on the cover
like I don't know how about Chris though
rock rock for example or maybe Stephen
Colbert Maria Bamford bill bird take
Notaro Rick and Morty Kate Berlant Nikki
Glaser Hannibal Buress Louie CK Norma
Connell no fielding Dave Chappelle Jim
Jeffries Sarah Silverman Bob Newhart The
Onion Steel Panther pieces of Keaton
Chung
ken Jeong Ali Wong Patton Oswalt every
member of the state every member of
Monty Python every comedian on another
period who were a lot of people from the
state Leslie Jones
Samantha P John Oliver Melissa McCarthy
Kumail Nanjiani Ron Funches a hamster in
a sweater or or this kid
[Applause]
comedians you coulda put on the cover of
your company issues I mean guys maybe
I'm personalizing this little much but
like do the jocks have to take this one
too do they have to take this one away
from the comedy nerd this kind of feels
like when maybe this is again too
personal for me but like when you're in
Chess Club your whole life and then a
football player puts on fake nerd
glasses and sits at a chess table and
that's the photograph for chess club in
the yearbook it's like they can't get
everything don't get me wrong I love the
rock he could be on the cover of
anything else and I'd be fine with the
use of world greatest action scarf maybe
he keeps not actually a comedian
I'd like an official professional
comedian actually he might not even be
the world's funniest rock I think this
is actually the world's funniest rock
and I think it's safe to say this one
has a much smaller penis but yeah I I
love you rock don't don't hit me don't
get mad at me this is my beepers with GQ
you didn't do anything wrong I just
don't understand the comedians in honor
of GQ magazine's a comedy issue I guess
please give me a less appropriate cover
person for a magazine Michael Starr bill
is you're on the cover sober and forever
magazine all right boy sick oscar
pistorius on functional legs quarterly
okay you know what yeah you did a bad
thing we can make fun of them all right
flexi-box limp Biskit on the cover of
Better Homes and Gardens all right boys